c'est un sujet très intéressant nous
avons testé aujourd'hui on va comparer
ces deux smartphones là on a ici et
l'iphone est ce de 2020 qui vient de
sortir il ya pas très longtemps et en
face l iphone 11 pro mac ce qui est un
iphone qui a été annoncé au mois de
septembre l'année dernière tous les deux
ont exactement la même puce d'apple
c'est la puce à 13 bionique sauf qu'ici
vous avez un smartphone qui coûte 4 189
euros et là vous avez un smartphone qui
coûte 1659 euros on adopte grosso modo
1900 euros d'écart entre ces deux
smartphones je vous explique pourquoi
j'ai fait soit je me suis longuement
posé la question au moment de faire ce
test mais se dit est-ce que je sors un
test seul pour parler de cet iphone ou
alors est-ce qu'il faut vraiment le
resituer dans un contexte global et
c'est vraiment le choix que j'ai faits
puisque apple nous fait la promesse
d'avoir en gros ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui chez lui en termes de
performances et grâce à la puce à 13
bionique eh bien on va regarder si cet
iphone là à 489 euros tient les
promesses qui sont faites par rapport à
ce qui se fait de mieux aujourd'hui chez
apple en ayant exactement la même puce
même si ces deux smartphones sont
difficilement comparables puisqu'il à
1200 euros d'écart entre les deux
néanmoins si l'iphone et ceux de 2020
n'est pas ridicule par rapport à ce
smartphone là ça veut dire qu'apple a
vraiment bien réussi sa copie et ça veut
donc dire qu'ils passent le test haut la
main et c'est un smartphone que je
pourrais vous recommander mais ça on
saura à la fin de la vidéo alors bien
évidemment ici vous avez un triplement
du photo je vais pas vous comparez un
triplement du photo avec un simple
module photo néanmoins dans les deux cas
vous avez 12 mégapixels avec l'ouverture
de f 1.8 dont il ya vraiment des
éléments comparaison entre ces deux
produits madoff
regardez aujourd'hui c'est un iphone 9 à
4 89 euros tient la route face à
l'iphone 9 à 1150 euros avant de
commencer il ya deux points que je
voulais voir avec vous vous m'avez
demandé en commentaire de comparer
l'iphone est ce de 2020 à l'iphone 8
notamment compte tenu du format pour moi
ils sont difficilement comparables
puisque même si vous êtes dans le même
idée dans le même design l'iphone it est
un smartphone qui a vraiment vieilli et
qui n'est plus actuel il ya donc pour
moi pas du tout d'intérêt d'aller
comparer aujourd'hui un iphone et ceux
de 2020 avec l'iphone 8 c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai pas retenu ce choix
là le deuxième demande qui m'a été faite
c est ce que tu peux comparer l'iphone
est ce de 2020 à l'iphone 10 r pour moi
c'est pareil sont de smartphones qui
sont difficilement opposable pourquoi
parce que l'iphone 10 r on a un écran de
plus de 6 pouces donc on cherche le
meilleur rapport qualité prix par
rapport à un iphone 10 par rapport à un
iphone 11 c'est vraiment dans cette idée
là qu'on vient regarder si l'iphone dit
certes potentiellement être intéressant
que messi on
monde de comparer par rapport à celui là
c'est uniquement sur la question du prix
pour voir si un iphone 10r qui
aujourd'hui a quand même un petit peu
mais c'est très intéressant par rapport
à l'iphone et ceux de 2020 si c'est
juste une question de prix je vous
invite à les visionner ma vidéo qui
s'appelle téléphones achetés en 2020 que
j'ai publié il ya peut-être un mois et
demi effectivement il n'y pas l'iphone
et ce2 dedans plus n'était pas sorti
néanmoins je vous parle de l'iphone et
ceux et je vous parle du format c'est
exactement la même réflexion si vous
cherchez un petit format iphone et ceux
de 2020 et si vous voulez un autre
iphone l'iphone 10r l'iphone 8 ou
l'iphone 10 ou l'iphone 11
et bien vous allez voir la vidéo se
donne un des éléments de réponse à
l'intérieur on va donc commencer tout de
suite par comparer ces deux modèles
c'est évident et si koné sur deux
produits qui sont littéralement opposé
on va pas rechercher du tout la même
chose
voyez ce grand écran que vous avez ce
petit écran vous avez avec ses grands
bords au niveau de l'iphone et ce2 si
quelqu'un veut acheter cet iphone os 2
c'est vraiment pour le format squeezé
question c'est quand même beaucoup plus
petits on n'aura pas le même confort de
visionnage mais au moins tu iphone et
ceux de 2020 est intéressant pourquoi
parce qu'il est extrêmement compact
obtient très très facilement de la même
manière on peut l'utiliser facilement à
une main ce qu'on veut tout de suite
beaucoup moins bien avec un iphone aussi
grand là il faut l'utiliser par contre à
demain l'iphone et se pèse 148 grammes
tandis que l'iphone os promax pèse 226
grammes la différence de poids quand
même significatif et entonnant comme ça
à la main je le sens vraiment j'ai hâte
de voir disparaître ces encoches en tout
cas elle devrait pouvoir se rétrécir
cette année donc ça ça pourrait vraiment
un excellent point néanmoins les
finances promax est aujourd'hui dans les
codes actuels par contre l'iphone est ce
qu'il est un petit peu rétro il est
vraiment old school avec cette grande
barre en haut c'est le grande barre en
bas avec tom shayes dit si vous voulez
aller sur ce produit une fois de plus
pas pour un design révolutionnaire mais
c'est vraiment pour un format
extrêmement compact sans la face arrière
par contre je trouve vraiment très très
actuelle sur l'iphone est ce vous avez
du verre à l'avant mais également
l'arrière plus de l'aluminium temps
qu'est-ce que tu en es phone 11 promax
vous avez du verre à l'avant à l'arrière
un verre ma texture est par contre vous
avez de l'acier inoxydable et dans tous
les cas que ce soit l'un ou l'autre en
smartphones qu'il faut venir protéger je
vous conseille vraiment de diamètre une
coque de protection grâce à mon
partenaire et nos fils chéri nos sites
vous avez plusieurs solutions qui
existent pour venir protéger votre
iphone vous menez la mettre dedans c'est
très sympa ça marche vous avez beaucoup
de choix ça c'est plutôt bien ce soit
seront en effet bois ou quelque chose un
petit peu plus quand date ce sont des
coques de protection antichoc on
protéger votre smartphone contre les
chutes au quotidien vous avez également
des bumper qui vont laisser apparaître
la face avant mais également la face
arrière de smartphones que vous
utilisiez une coque ou un bumper il vous
faut une protection d'écran pour venir
protéger l'écran bien évidemment de
votre smartphone et dans le cas du 20
heures il vous faut également tenir le
protéger à l'arrière pour éviter qu'en
tombant en veine abîmé le vert à l'arrêt
vous avez pas mal de choix en terme de
finition et surtout ça j'aime beaucoup
puisque vous avez la nouvelle collection
aérospatiale avec un design qui a prouvé
par la nasa
regardez celle là par exemple pour
l'iphone os pronax elle est vraiment
cool vous avez donc plein de
possibilités de personnalisation et si
vous êtes du genre à casser vocable ils
ont des caps tressé de 1,2 à 3 mètres en
fibre d'aramide et celui-là pendant le
casse et il va falloir vous y mettre
vous avez bien évidemment plein de
coques pour iphone mais également pour
android vous avez -10% sherin au sud
avec nos codes gros 2020 grrr 2020 il
s'affichera à l'écran et je vous ai mis
le lien aller faire un petit tour
c'est dans la description l'iphone est
ce un écran de 4,7 pouces dali ps et du
lcd est à l'écran retina hd qu'une
résolution 2334 par 750 pixels à 326
pixels par pouce avec une luminosité
maximale de 600 vanity tandis que
l'iphone ans promax un écran de 6 5
pouces un écran oled super et tina x hd
un écran hd est vrai qu'une résolution
de 2006 188 parmi 242 pixels à 658
pixels par pouce avec une luminosité
maximale de 800 litres qui dit écran
oled 10 et des noirs infinie dit de
meilleur contraste par rapport à ce que
vous allez voir ici sur une dalle lcd
néanmoins pour les prendre il y à garder
que je puis vous assurer comme ça c'est
extrêmement bluffant l'écran de l'iphone
est super tendance à tirer un petit peu
plus sur bleu tandis que celui de
l'iphone os promax dire un peu plus sur
le jeune je trouve l'écran de l'iphone
os promax plus fluide mais ça reste
vraiment dehors du point de détail
puisque les deux fonctionnent vraiment
très très bien concernant la qualité de
visionnage sur des séries comme netflix
youtube ou ce que vous voulez la qualité
de visionnage est très bonne pour les
deux quelle que soit votre smartphone
qu'il ya un autre point qui est
également très intéressant c'est que
dans les deux cas vous avez des hauts
parleurs stéréo je vous prends l'exemple
dans les finances pour max on va
utiliser le haut parleur vous avez ici
mais également le haut parleur vous avez
sur le devant qui va bien vous donner un
effet de spatialisation c'est exactement
la même chose sur l'iphone est ce la
différence que vous allez vraiment avoir
entre les deux c'est que sans les forces
pro gbagbo d'aller voir en sont avec un
spectre plus large
bien évidemment des haut parleurs ils
seront plus puissants un son plus grave
et un son plus médium alors c'est pas un
petit son médium qui fait qu un coin on
voit que le spectre est diminuée mais ça
paraît normal dans les deux car vous
avez une expérience audio de qualité
donc d'une manière un peu global pour le
côté multimédia et bien vous avez un
iphone et ce2 qui fait vraiment la faire
et il n'a pas du tout à rougir par
rapport à son grand frère
autre point non des moindres c'est la
question de la performance et c'est pour
moi un des points essentiels est un des
points les plus intéressants puisque
c'est une des promesses faites par apple
de vous dire ok on nous sort un iphone
s2 à moins de 500 euros
on arrive vraiment dans des tarifs
milieu diane mais par contre on vous est
notre meilleure puce c'est la puce à 13
bionique ça veut dire dans un iphone à
moins de 500 euros
j'ai la même puce que dans un iphone à
plus de 1600 euros et ça c'est vachement
intéressant on s'attend donc à voir
exactement les mêmes performances dans
l'absolu c'est pas faux mais c'est pas
non plus complètement vrai j'ai voulu
appuyer sur un benchmark tautou pour
vous montrer ça sur l'iphone et ceux de
2020 vous avez un résultat de 444 1298
tels que sur iphone os promax vous avez
résultats de 540 1304 néanmoins je puis
vous assurer qu'avec un résultat de 444
1298 et vu les résultats obtenus et bien
les fans et ceux de 2020 est un
smartphone qui est vraiment très
performant et qui vous décevra
absolument pas de ce côté là l'autonomie
sera aussi moins bonnes mais da bien
évidemment dépendre de vos usages entre
l'île journée à deux jours ça dépend
vraiment de ce que vous allez en faire
la vraie différence que vous allez avoir
là dessus c'est d'un point de vue
purement expérientiel cclat vous avez un
chargeur de 18 watts qui inclus dans la
boîte et qui vous leur charge quand même
assez rapidement ici la recharge n'est
pas rapide il faut vous armer de
patience
par contre le point positif est ce qu
ils vraiment bien si vous avez de la
recharge sans fil de l'expérience au
niveau de l'eau et c'est exactement le
même qu est ce que vous avez à ios 13
d'un côté et de l'autre mettant un des
usages aussi extrêmement important c'est
la question de la partie photo pyl que
vous avez d'un côté de l'autre au niveau
de la caméra principale qui va être la
caméra grand angle même pas du trac
quand on parle bien effectivement de
grand-angle qu'ils avaient dans les deux
cas un capteur de 12 mégapixels et un
objectif qui ouvre à f 108 vous avez si
une stabilisation optique
ici vous avez une double stabilisation
optique bien évidemment l'iphone
on se promet xv ira beaucoup plus loin
au niveau des photos mais au moins ce
qu'on peut faire a écrit fan est ce que
vous allez voir c'est quand même plutôt
pas mal
je vous montre le résultat et le kosovo
pour dire ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire si je voulais prendre je
voulais pose comme ça sans vous dire
quel smartphone fait quoi et bien c'est
quand même difficile de les partager
on continue avec une rose dont il était
que vous avez ici les gouttes d'eau d'un
côté et de l'autre toujours une rose et
bien voyez dans les deux cas le résultat
est vraiment bien à moins de 500 euros
avec l'iphone est ce vous avez un
photophone qui se fait vraiment bien le
tas on continue avec une photo qui était
prise
le studio dans les deux cas le rendu
qualitatif cette fois ci avec le mode
portrait alors là il ya une différence
et c'est normal puisque l'iphone on se
prend max ne va pas faire des photos
avec le mode portrait avec la caméra
principale il va utiliser le
téléobjectif le détourage n'a pas été
idéale entre les deux doigts ici alors
que de l'autre côté sur l'iphone et ce
et bien voyez le rendu quand même plutôt
bien un peu de mal ici mais bon il faut
de plus ça c'est du fun détails mais là
où la différence est vraiment flagrante
et bien sûr les photos en faible
luminosité
j'ai coupé toutes les lumières dans le
studio il photos sont prises exactement
dans les mêmes conditions
l'iphone et ce n'a pas d'exposition
l'ong a du mal à me sentir des photos
lorsque vous n'avez pas beaucoup de
lumière tandis que l'iphone on se prend
max s'en sort quand même beaucoup mieux
autres photos prises dans les mêmes
conditions avec iphone 11 promax vous
avez vraiment tout le personnage vous
avez bien le détail il ya un peu de
bruit derrière mais néanmoins rendu est
vraiment là tandis que l'iphone est ce
bien voyez en condition sable de
luminosité il se retrouve pas du tout et
on finit avec une photo prise avec la
caméra de celle fille rien de bien
particulier à dire là dessus ça fait le
boulot
donc voyez et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant et bien l'iphone et ce n'a
absolument pas à rougir par rapport à
l'iphone 11 promax donc si vous voulez
un smartphone qui fait de bonnes photos
à moins de 500 euros et bien vous ne
serait absolument pas déçu dans les deux
cas vous avez du wifi 6 dans les deux
cas vous avez du bluetooth 5.0 dans les
deux cas vous avez du nfc bien
évidemment apple paix dans les deux cas
vous avez une nano symplus unis sim vous
avez nullement une différence en termes
de certification sont les finances
promet une certification qui paie 68 sur
l'iphone et ce 2020 vous avez une
certification ip67 la grosse différence
c'est que vous pouvez laisser à 4 mètres
pendant 30 minutes dans l'eau lui à un
mètre pendant 30 minutes
bon dans tous les cas on va éviter de se
baigner avec comme ça moi voudront
absolument aucun problème
néanmoins s'il rend compte de l'eau s'il
ya des projections et s'il pleut vous
serez protégés que les voyez ça c'est
assez dingue en fait c'est que on se
retrouve avec un smartphone sur le plus
haut de gamme sur la plus grosse qu'à
pas en passant douzillac écoute 1659
euros l'âge est un smartphone avec 64
giga de stockage c'est l'iphone le moins
cher tarifs 9 qui coûte 4 189 euros
j'ai à peu près 1200 euros d'écart entre
ces deux smartphones et c'est là où on
voit que c'est vraiment intéressant est
que cet iphone et ce est vraiment bien
c'est lorsqu'on vient de comparer et
convient situer par rapport à ce
qu'apple ses ennemis aujourd'hui
eh bien je puis vous assurer que si vous
voulez un iphone et ce2
il vint vous ne serez pas déçus apple
pour moi a bien réussi sa copie une fois
de plus je le dis et je le redis
si on veut acheter l'iphone est ce 2020
c'est parce qu'on veut un petit format
c'est parce qu'on veut smartphone
compact qu'on peut ranger facilement
dans une poche dans un sac à main qui se
laisse oublier qu'on peut utiliser très
facilement à une main et qu'il ira très
bien avec beaucoup d'usagers sans en
faire trop
voilà mon retour sur cet iphone et ce
2020 j'espère qu'il vous aura convaincu
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire est ce que vous
pourriez vous laisser tenter
est ce que vous vous êtes déjà laissé
tenter sur ce je vous fais des gros
bisous je donne rendez vous demain pour
mieux parler tech
allez vous embrasse 10 minutes chacun
[Musique]